riskantes manöver auf der autobahn auf
einem stark befahrenen highway im us
bundesstaat ohio liegt ein fahrer
plötzlich den rückwärtsgang ein verkehrs
überwachungskameras filmen die
lebensgefährliche aktion ganze vier
minuten kurz das auto rückwärts durch
die gegend in der nähe eines
lebensmittelladens kommt es schließlich
zum stehen
die verkehrsbehörde von ohio teilte auf
ihrer facebook-seite mit zum glück sei
bei dem vorfall niemand verletzt worden
warum der fahrer rückwärts fuhr ist
bislang nicht bekannt
die behörde vermute dass er eventuell
probleme mit dem getriebe hatte
[Musik]